You're an
Alien you're super
powerful you recently saved the world
with your
friends what do you like to do for
fun
Vengeance I was thinking more like
reading or or or
yoga hey Buddy isn't it great to finally
relax I am been a kid no Warrior
I only remain on Earth because I made a
vow to you and the fox so I made myself
at
home nope we are not turning our living
room into some kind of gladiator
fighting pit what is aie doing here he
will be challenging his greatest
enemy
you is that our
mailman this is not a place of battle so
I will begin my Quest come weed most
people think I'm a joke I do not make
jokes I make
warriors let's go get
him
knuckles without his little friends he's
vulnerable he's the key to all my newest
creation you worked for
Robotnik bring me
knuckles
sorry this Lane is reserved you think
you can take my
power do I look like I need your power
what are you talking about of course we
need his power it's the whole reason
we're
here your
mine I made a
promise to protect this
planet I am
am ready oh snap someone's about to get
[Applause]
slapped I think today is going to be a
beautiful
day help me you going to rescue him no
he must learn to rescue
himself there go let you
[Applause]
up